[Música]
precisamente como comentábamos nuestro
segundo invitado del día es una
eminencia mundial en la investigación
del Alzheimer es Francisco lopera y su
equipo encontró dos casos de estudio
Aquí en Colombia que podrían ayudar a
combatir esta enfermedad precisamente
Contamos con nuestra especialista en
salud nuestra periodista más Romero sala
le pido que brevemente nos ayude a
contextualizar esta entrevista Así es
rosa la noticia salió el 15 de mayo
Nosotras también la dimos aquí en France
24 y es una investigación del grupo
de la Universidad de Antioquia que
detectó una segunda persona resistente
al Alzheimer a la aparición de esta
demencia especialmente porque hay unos
pueblos particularmente yarumal en
Antioquia donde se ha heredado una
mutación llamada coloquialmente La
mutación paisa que hace que la gente
desarrolle Alzheimer precoz alrededor de
los 45 años sin embargo hay dos dos
casos a liria fue la primera el paciente
J fue el segundo que se anunció este año
que que pese a tener esta mutación Paisa
No tuvieron Alzheimer hasta mucho tiempo
después se retrasó esta esta aparición
de la enfermedad así que bueno esto
brevemente son las pinceladas sobre la
investigación del doctor lopera
Muchísimas gracias mar Ahora sí momento
de saludar y al doctor lopera aquí en
France 24 Muchísimas gracias por
atendernos por estar con nosotros en
nuestro programa directo América
Muchas gracias por invitarme al programa
mar y
le pregunto por qué estas dos personas
no desarrollaron alzheimer
bueno estas dos personas tenían
al mismo tiempo que tenían un gen de
causalidad para para la enfermedad de
alzheimer tenían otro Gen mutado que los
protegía de la enfermedad
aliria era portadora de una mutación en
el Gen apoe tres
Y esa mutación la protegió durante 30
años del inicio de los síntomas de la
enfermedad y al paciente J
él tenía otra mutación en otro Gen
llamado que nosotros lo lo llamamos
rileyn colmos y esa mutación lo protegió
de la enfermedad de alzheimer por 26
años
doctor Cómo se puede ahora que ustedes
de hecho han encontrado estas mutaciones
Cómo se puede reproducir esta protección
natural que les da a estas personas
contra la aparición del Alzheimer a Pues
a un medicamento o un tratamiento
sabemos que está lejos Pero que pueda
servir para todo el mundo bueno estos
dos descubrimientos de variantes
protectoras podrían tener implicaciones
terapéuticas para prevenir y para curar
el alzheimer hay dos maneras de aplicar
esto uno sería la terapia génica es
decir
utilizar el la información genética
protectora la variante protectora y
introducirla por ejemplo dentro de un
vector viral y producir una infección
viral que no es viral sino informática y
de esa manera se podría retrasar por 26
o 30 años el inicio de los síntomas
obviamente es más fácil decirlo que
hacerlo pero teóricamente es posible
desarrollar terapia génica la otra
alternativa es desarrollar un
medicamento que imite el mecanismo de
acción de la mutación protectora en el
cerebro de una persona que tiene riesgo
de alto riesgo de enfermedad de
alzheimer Y eso también podría ser uno
de las de las rutas que se desarrolla el
medicamentos que imiten ese mecanismo de
acción
y Francisco le preguntó después de
tantos años estudiando una población tan
particular aquí en Colombia que han
aprendido con su equipo de esta
enfermedad del Alzheimer
bueno nosotros lo hemos dicho de una
manera muy sencilla lo que hemos
aprendido en 40 años es que
un nuevo método para prevenir y curar la
enfermedad de alzheimer porque la la
lección más importante que hemos hemos
aprendido es que la enfermedad y la cura
habitan en la naturaleza Entonces en
realidad no habría que inventar una cura
para el alzheimer lo que habría que
hacer es leer la naturaleza y copiarla
ese es como el aprendizaje más grande
que hemos tenido un aprendizaje que
ojalá también escuche mucha gente
alrededor del mundo que también sigue
investigando el alzheimer yo le quería
preguntar particularmente por el
medicamento que ustedes estuvieron
investigando durante varios años también
en la población
de Antioquia que tiene esta mutación un
medicamento que se llama crenezumap no y
que buscaba limpiar las placas de
amiloide que se está proteína que se
acumula en el cerebro en las personas
que tienen Alzheimer el estudio no
arrojó resultados que permitieran que se
siguiera avanzando pero yo le quería
preguntar particularmente que hablamos
tanto de estos estudios que son exitosos
que sucede con los aprendizajes de los
estudios que no arrojan esos datos que
uno quizás esperaba al principio
bueno bar Yo creo que lo más importante
es que ese estudio que duró ocho años y
no mostró una eficacia fue negativo
sin embargo fue positivo en el sentido
de que ese estudio fue el que nos
permitió encontrar estos dos casos de
seres protegidos porque justamente
gracias a ese estudio vinieron al centro
estas dos personas que querían
participar en el estudio ellos no ellos
no pudieron participar del estudio
apicolombia porque no cumplían todos los
requisitos pero fueron evaluados fueron
estudiados y encontramos que eran seres
protegidos Entonces por un lado hubo un
fracaso en cuanto al que el medicamento
no no funcionó no fue efectivo pero por
otro lado tuvimos un gran éxito Porque
descubrimos estos dos casos que nos
trajeron una enseñanza impresionante y
además están mostrando una vía para la
cura y para la solución que no logro
Mostrar el medicamento experimental Sí
incluso Saber que algo no funciona es
una información valiosa definitivamente
y yo le quería terminar o seguir
preguntando también por el futuro de
estas tratamientos de estas curas del
Alzheimer Y qué opinaba usted de estos
tratamientos que siguen con el camino de
limpiar las placas de amiloide del
cerebro Ahora hay un medicamento el
decanemap no que se está debatiendo su
aprobación en Estados Unidos está
debatiendo su aprobación también en los
reguladores europeos y que genera
algunas dudas y también muchas
esperanzas y por eso pues teniéndolo
hasta aquí quería preguntarle qué opina
de estos tratamientos que buscan limpiar
el amiloide del cerebro bueno
probablemente limpiar el amiloide solo
no es suficiente Eso es lo que nos
enseñan estos dos casos protegidos que
estaban llenos de amiloides pero estaban
protegidos de Tao entonces muy
probablemente lo que se va a poner de
moda es las terapias combinadas
utilizando un antiamiloideo y un anti
tau de hecho ese es el paso siguiente
que vamos a hacer aquí en Colombia vamos
a iniciar un estudio con Diane
Universidad de Washington utilizando un
medicamento antitado y otro antiamiloide
en población con alzheimer genético
doctor y para terminar así no no sé si
queríamos preguntarle también Al final
una pequeña reflexión sobre cómo es
hacer ciencia investigación en Colombia
y codearse con investigaciones de
Estados Unidos de otros lugares que
tienen más recursos tienen el idioma no
cómo ha sido Pues a convertirse en un
foco de investigación en un país del sur
global
bueno el hecho es que como tenemos una
un un un un una población demasiado
interesante para el mundo y es una
población única entonces y hemos hecho
un trabajo muy juicioso de seguimiento
de esa población durante 40 años hemos
logrado hacer hacer digamos alianzas
internacionales y tener un
reconocimiento internacional que nos ha
permitido conseguir los los recursos los
fondos y las colaboraciones para avanzar
en estas investigaciones Porque
indudablemente estos trabajos que
estamos publicando no los hemos hecho
solos los hemos hecho con otros grupos y
además con colombianos que se formaron
en el grupo de Colombia pero que ahora
son líderes mundiales en la
investigación de alzheimer en otros
centros del mundo y Francisco para
cerrar una pregunta Que supongo que le
hacen a menudo y es para las personas
que padecen esta enfermedad o para sus
familiares qué tan cerca en términos de
tiempo estaríamos de una cura
Bueno ya he estado diciendo últimamente
que creo que en los próximos cinco años
vamos a tener medicamentos mucho más
eficaces para la enfermedad de alzheimer
y en diez años Espero que tengamos
medicamentos bastante eficaces y que
podamos controlar bastante la enfermedad
Francisco pues muchísimas gracias de
verdad por acercarnos de forma tan
pedagógica todo su conocimiento y su
investigación sobre el Alzheimer a
ustedes por darme la oportunidad de
contar sobre todo estos avances Mary
Muchísimas gracias también por ayudarnos
a entender esta investigación pionera
aquí en Colombia Seguiremos actualizando
la rosa y nosotras hacemos una breve
pausa pero enseguida regresamos con más
noticias